another black man who has been falsely
accused another victim of systemic
racism and CNN has the report about this
Nevada rapper uh Nevada rapper was
arrested on a murder charge after Las
Vegas Police said that he confessed to
the murder in his song lyrics
kenwan McDaniel was arrested August 29th
on the charge of open murder with a
deadly weapon his bail was set Thursday
at 1 million dollars with electronic
monitoring according to court records
McDaniel has been considered a person of
interest in the death of Randall Wallace
on September 18 2021 in part due to his
connection to a vehicle that matched the
description of one used during the crime
detectives noted the music a music video
that was posted in July
from McDaniel bore a sufficient level of
similarity to the details of the murder
this includes the fact that kenwon
confessed to the murder in his lyrics
details provided by kenwan in his music
video were not released to the public
and would not be common knowledge the
Warren said one lyric included in the
warrant is quote there's the lyric in
the video park the car double back on
feet the smartest way to slide drove in
double lock your man make sure you got
your bod
I don't know what that means double lock
your man make sure you got yobad
anyway the warrant states that that is
those are details
of the killing so apparently in the
actual okay we don't know exactly what
happened to killing but apparently in
The Killing uh yo man was double locked
and they made sure they got yobod so
that did happen in the crime
and then it it shows up the looks anyway
I just want to make sure I have this
straight
uh
someone is shot and killed
and you just assume that it's kenwan
McDaniel just because
his car was at the scene of the crime
and he also described the crime in
graphic detail in a song and actually
confessed to committing it so
just because of that
he's a suspect
come on
just come on
if I was just public defender that would
be the case I would make to the judge
your honor
come on
relax all right just let's be cool about
this well it's fall which means cozy
nights with my family thanks to my
friends at Tommy John my loungewear for
a night in has the perfect blend of
comfort and breathability their
loungewear has a level of softness like
I've never felt before they're
incredibly soft loungewear is designed
to envelope envelop you in a world of
pure luxury when you wear Tommy John
you're so much more comfortable that you
can do everything better even their
underwear has dozens of comfort
Innovations like breathable lightweight
moisture wicking fabric with four times
the stretch of competing brands that you
keep you at seven degrees cooler than
cotton every purchase is backed by Tommy
John's best pair you'll ever wear or
it's free guaranteed get 20 off your
first order right now at tommyjohn.com
Walsh that's 20 at tommyjohn.com Welsh
Seaside for details
but we know what's really going on here
kenwan was arrested because he's black
because he's black
and because this car was at the scene of
the crime and because he confessed to
the murder in a song but mostly because
he's black
and I want to say something else about
kenwa McDaniel and I know I know a lot
about this guy I've been following his
career for a long time this man was
turning his life around
okay he was he was uh he would uh and he
was he was a good kid he won the
spelling bee in second grade
I mean that didn't happen he probably
wouldn't he wouldn't win a second grade
spelling bee today but he did he was
about to get accepted into medical
school he was turning his life around
and now this
so actually let's listen to a little bit
I think we have the song Don't We yeah
we do have it okay so we have this song
A little bit of the song where he
allegedly confessed to the murder and I
think
there you know the cops say that this
song implicates him I think it
vindicates them I I think that you that
we can clearly show that he's not guilty
by this song when you listen to it and
I'll tell you why in a second but let's
listen
funnels down
uh song by the way is called fady free
and uh it's a great song it's been I've
been bumping it on my Spotify playlist
for months
I play it all the time in the car with
my kids they're I mean every time I play
it they're like oh is this fatty free
again Dad jeez so I'm a big fan uh but
this when you listen to the song you
know that he's innocent because there's
no way he confessed to the murder in
that song because he couldn't have
confessed to anything because he's not
speaking words he's not speaking an
actual human language of any kind and so
I mean how could he he's mumbling
incoherently so you know he I mean who
knows what he's saying is the point and
that that really should be the defense
by what I assume is going to be a public
defender uh that should be the defense
like your honor no one knows what the
hell this guy's saying in that song you
know we don't know he could be giving us
a cure for cancer for all we know he
could be um
he could be giving us a new recipe for a
great new uh ham and cheese quiche for
Halloween like he could be we don't know
nobody knows what he's saying he doesn't
even know what he's saying so if you
were to ask kenwell McDaniel what were
you trying to say in that song he would
not be able to tell you uh and so
therefore
he is innocent free free kenwan put that
on the T-shirt
uh another innocent man
like push iced tea being taken down by
the system it's a travesty thanks for
checking out this video if you'd like to
listen to my full podcast on the go you
can check out the Matt wall show on
Apple podcast Spotify or wherever you
get your podcasts